Here is a really tricky quiz. Let's look at the robot motion again.
Say I change the last measurement from 2 down to 1.
You might remember the robot poses were -3, 2, and 5.
Before that modification the landmark position was 7, but a 1 doesn't really add up.
A 1 suggests I might be at a different distance to the 7 than the 5 over here
that comes from this side.
Here is my quiz.
First, I want you to know if I make this modification what is the effect on x2?
Will the estimate be smaller than 5?
That is, we shrink the robot path a little bit?
Will it be exactly equal to 5 like before?
Or will it be larger than 5? Check exactly 1 of the three boxes.
I also want to know what is the effect on x0.
Will it be smaller than -3, equals -3, or larger than -3.
This is a completely nontrivial quiz.
It takes really some thinking.
Invest in thinking, and you can even go back and try it out.